Speaker 1: We're continuing to learn in fits
and starts and spurts and bits and pieces. I
don't know more and more about the extraordinarily
bizarre times at Mar a Lago related to this FBI
search warrant, the raid, the documents, etc.. And
the latest from The Washington Post is that Donald
Trump told a worker move boxes of documents
after the government subpoena was received,
which is another indicator, if true, that
Donald Trump knew exactly what was where and was
specifically involved in trying to hide documents
from authorities. Key witness and security camera
footage. There is video offer evidence of Trump's
actions after the government subpoena. People
familiar say look at this. A Trump employee
has told federal agents about moving boxes
of documents at Mar a Lago at the specific
direction of the former president. According
to people familiar with the investigation who say
the witness account, combined with security camera
footage, offers key evidence of Donald Trump's
behavior as investigators sought the return of
classified material. The witness description
and footage described to The Washington Post
offer the most direct account to date of Trump's
actions and instructions leading up to the FBI
search on August 8th. We're agents. We're
looking for evidence of potential crimes.
The people familiar with the investigation said
agents said agents have gathered witness accounts
indicating that this is the key element after
Trump advisers received a subpoena in May for
any classified documents remaining at Mar a Lago.
Trump told people move boxes to his residence at
the property. That description of events was
corroborated by security camera footage. There
is video which showed people moving the boxes,
said the people who spoke on the condition of
anonymity to discuss an ongoing investigation.
No comment from the Justice Department.
No comment from Trump's spokesman, Taylor Buda,
which, other than the Biden administration,
has weaponized law enforcement and fabricated a
document hoax in a desperate attempt to retain
political power? Folks, this is more evidence
of obstruction. This is Trump trying to hide his
alleged violations of the Espionage Act. This was
immediately called fake news. And then, of course,
it's oh, we have the footage, we have the video
footage, we have the surveillance footage showing
a staffer moving boxes out of the storage room
and moving them to another location. So there is
really one major story here, and many dozens
of you every single day write to me and say,
David, there's sort of like tons of evidence that
this guy obviously should be indicted. We're not
saying imprisoned. We're saying evidence for an
indictment and then go through the process and
determine whether there is guilt. The real
story here to me continues to be the DOJ,
Department of Justice, FBI, law enforcement,
federal law enforcement investigating all of this.
They have an almost absurd amount of evidence
at this point in time to justify an indictment.
Doesn't guarantee a guilty verdict. It doesn't
guarantee necessarily even a guilty plea. But
if this were anyone other than a former president,
there is such extensive evidence that there would
have been an indictment already. Why is there
no indictment? Is Merrick Garland not actually
willing to indict? We had this investigation in
New York, which we covered. And if you've been
watching, the show may ring a bell in which two
of the investigators resigned. And of course,
when this happened, the Trumpists all came out of
the woodwork and they had the same story ready to
go. And that story was, oh, the investigators
resigned because they realized it's a witch
hunt and there's no evidence that was wrong. The
resignations were actually quite the opposite.
The investigators resigned because despite all of
the evidence they were finding, they believed that
there was not actually a willingness from higher
ups to indict Trump. They felt the investigators
felt as though their work was completely in
vain, that they were doing the work. They
were finding the evidence. And yet they would
bring it, bring it, bring it to their bosses.
And they sensed a total lack of willingness
from their bosses to actually go through with
an indictment. They said, What the hell are we
doing here? We're working in vain. We're working
for nothing. And they resigned at this point
in time. And we will see as we're recording
today's show. The January six committee hearing is
taking place scheduled to start momentarily. You
will probably know more about it than I know
now. By the time today's episode goes live,
the amount of evidence is really piling up here.
Are we going to get an indictment? And remember,
I'm actually for Law and Order. So when I say,
are we going to get an indictment, I don't go
to lock anybody up. I don't go to railroad
anyone with charges. What I go to is there
seems to be enough evidence for an indictment.
That's the step I'm talking about. The right,
on the other hand, claims to be for law and order.
And yet they say, lock up, Hillary. Lock up Joe
Biden. Lock up Hunter Biden. Lock up Antifa.
Lock up BLM. Lock up people who haven't even
been charged and in many cases who aren't even
under investigation. That's not law and order.
Law and order is look at all this evidence against
Trump. It's time to indict. That's where we are.